um
i have with me david pakman he is a
progressive host
[Music]
an executive producer of the nationally
syndicated radio and tv
program the david pacman show
and i wanted to talk to david pakman he
is a baby
david pacman he is
david pacman he is
can you remind the audience when you
talk about
being a beta male and being an alpha
male what are we talking about
here there are males most men today
yeah male 1 they think and act like a
woman they are emotional
they are mentally off they have no logic
and that's a beta male they go along
with homosexuality hold on but holy whoa
whoa jesse well we we gotta
that's a lot etc that's a lot agree with
everything that's raw abortion they
think and act just like a woman a beta
male died
but another baby doesn't because he's a
logical thinking
and they're controlled by the darkness
of david pakman
he is a baby
david pac-man he is
[Applause]
he is a beta male 1
david patman he is a male 1
david pacman he
david is he is a pain
david you're not here to communicate i
really appreciate you coming out i'm
going to let you go it's a waste of time
to talk to you
we're not communicating you're actually
like because you're asking bizarre
questions you're actually like
an idiot and you're wasting my time i
appreciate that
all right thanks for coming goodbye
[Music]
goodbye
[Music]
it doesn't
all right welcome everybody what a day
we are live and now by popular demand
uh in 60 frames per second if you can
believe it so we have a huge event today
joe biden is going to philadelphia
the center of i don't even know what
he's going to philadelphia a city in the
united states where he is going to
i believe unload on republican voter
suppression
uh and why are we covering this that's a
really great question the reason we're
covering this
is because you told me this is one of
your
most important uh issues we actually
pulled
the youtube audience look at these
numbers i got a call from my orthopedist
today he said he'd never seen numbers
like this
which campaign promise should biden
prioritize
a hundred and seven that what is wrong
with my hair
a hundred and seven thousand of you
voted
you know john mclaughlin uh he gets
1500 people to vote in his polls 107
000 votes and 45 of you meaning roughly
45 000 of you said
voting rights act voting rights voting
rights voting rights
and so that's why we are here and
standing by
for joseph r biden jr yes the president
by the way um to talk about
exactly that issue all right so we're
standing by and i think it's going to be
a really really strong
strong speech and we i just have so much
to talk about today
um where to even start
uh well we'll quit just so i don't fall
behind life is good
kay gouldy the retired the old
tired road as well as unforgiven two
have just signed up via twitch prime
putting us at four
we will open phone lines today
heretofore unannounced we will open
phone lines today if we get to 100
website members
slingblade has just signed up number
five
and also from the perspective of my
website
thaddeus schnuel has just become a new
website member with the coupon code
sad trump thaddeus schneel
new member number six today
just stunning stunning stuff
so what do we have to go over today i
have clips of
mask and covid related breakdowns
i have super chats i have voicemails
um i have conspiracy theories
oh and i have unbanned requests as well
but let me wait on those
i have a super chat from pepe xanadu who
says
why does skin color still matter today
you would need to elaborate a little bit
i don't know exactly what you mean by
that but i would need you to elaborate a
little bit
also thank you to lerdon
for the twitch prime subscription very
much appreciate that
let's get right into a couple of
voicemails we are now as many of you
remember we went on vacation on june
25th
and we've been working through the
voicemails we're up to july
1st if you can imagine today's july 13th
and we're only up to july 1st on
voicemails
let's just keep going a little bit okay
hey david it's ryan i was calling you
know i wanted to
talk a little bit about some of these
medical segments with
you know nurses or doctors all these
crazy conspiracy theories and trump
views and
and you know on your episode today you
said hey
you know we thought we had seen it all
but none of this has surprised me at all
i was actually the operations manager
for a group of four medical clinics and
this is what
the pandemic has really been showing us
is just
how much the trump era has radicalized
people
not based on education alone but really
just
if they were on the right the era just
pushed them so far
to the right and and well said very well
said okay a nice voicemail
um here's another one
i was just looking at some of the
devastation in india now i know many of
you will say oh this girl again i'm just
going in order this is what i promised
you to prove i'm not hand picking
india women are being like
degraded and turned into sex trafficking
workers
they're like for like ninety dollars
these men you like eat them and stuff
like that
um i don't hear like too much from tulsi
on
like relations with india tulsi what on
earth is going on here okay let's keep
going
hi david i'd like to lay this uh outdoor
mask issue to rest
um i'm a paragon of trail etiquette
here at the state park local state park
i do a lot of trail riding here in our
state park
and uh i'll tell you i'm widely
recognized here i've been doing i do a
lot of trail riding
and i'll tell you i i i keep up asked on
that person i wear it around there's a
55
in older community okay all right he's
wearing a mask
okay so it worries me that i feel like
nobody really cares about
the slaves or slavery in general
i mean that's probably why they were in
place in the first place
i know people are saying how is it this
same girl again
i'm going in order to show you what the
voicemail inbox is like
it seems to me like maybe the muslims
are using both
um the black people and the white people
speaking leverage in society
i mean if you had a bible or something
that said like
that women are of unequal intelligence
it kind of gives me the assumption that
maybe those people
might lack motivation all right that
goes a full three minutes but we're
going to just
continue so i found an article from
dartmouth college on a professor who
said that obama is definitely a muslim
alabama yes exactly what number do i
call to leave a voicemail
asks alex howell the number is 219 to
david p hey david
i was watching the live stream today
with talking about the indictment
um and you played something uh from an
old clip from an old show
and you played it in a faster speed and
i hate to tell you this
but you sounded a little bit like ben
shapiro
i heard that from a lot of different
people actually from a lot of different
people
hi david this is crazy nate from youtube
a.k.a nathan quimby from your
website and i'm just calling to tell you
that
about the no they go out they're just
giving a ton of personal information so
we can't do that
so i looked online about like
influential muslims and
ones that um like did something for
society or
you know have high iq levels and it
seems like they're all leaders
like their position is just to stand
there and
that's enough and i'll just do one more
hey david what's going on i'm actually
watching your stream and i'm seeing
the pain in your face from getting a ton
of voicemails that are unusable
luckily i watch the show i think i know
how it works so i'm going to wing it
please don't roast me
if it's unusable okay i'm really trying
my best um so trump returning right and
having this rally and having
you know building up all these other
like little mini trumpians all over the
country
right it got me thinking of okay well
clearly the republican party is going in
a trumpian way
um when the presidential election comes
around though i can't think of
any like trumpian people that
have any chance of winning it's not
trump uh trump himself for like the
presidential
election actually i think ron desantis
has a real shot
something is really weird going on with
my hair today all right so let's get
away from that because i can tell people
are getting a little bit
distraught by it i don't want to upset
anybody i do want to say thank you to a
danish joint
radeboyks valksi kaklouy
and try gamer all of whom just grabbed
twitch prime subscriptions putting us at
12 for the day
very much appreciate it the coupon code
indictment 21 does work
at joinpakman.com all right let's get
right into
unbanned requests when you use twitch
and you get banned because
you're extremely juvenile and presumably
live a sad life that leads you to
do things that get you banned um you can
appeal that and request to be unbanned i
have three
such requests to adjudicate today the
first
is a user who goes by the name
uh christopher canine who said
please mercy ban me this speech
this is the trump speech is worsening my
mental health and depression
they were banned by request and then
they said watching trump worsens my
bipolar depressive symptoms
thank you for the mercy ban i've had a
few minutes to reflect and breathe and
i'm ready to rejoin the community very
good
unban approved
all right number two here is a user
named bty
fife who came in and said
weinstein stuff five on the flight
you had to add that david loves hot
gas on his face she would think
he would throw in some mr presidents
besides sir weird coincidence sir
a lot of noise from your chat
don't you love it two zionists
they were banned i mean it's just kind
of more annoying than anything else
and then they said i thought it was
zionist
it i think being me so it's so
unintelligible
that that is a perma-ban all right
and then another user who goes by the
name
nick streams showed up and said what's
the deal with mail in voting
sick democrats a
yeah yeah lol yup i a
o and all sorts of other just like three
letter
kind of guttural sounds they were banned
then they said i don't even want to be
unbanned this is a soft ass echo chamber
democrats only
all right well that's just a perma ban i
guess
and i'm not i'm not even a democrat kind
of all weird
okay so we've adjudicated the unban
requests
i do want to say thank you to harland
nelson harlan just signed up on my
website joinedpakman.com using the
coupon code better21
and his new member number 13. there has
never been a better day to become a
member
there's never been a worse day either to
be totally transparent but there's never
been a better day
if we get to a hundred phone lines are
opening
i also want to say thank you to mortar
stroller
asf clops hanging from
gallows for the twitch prime
subscriptions
putting us at 16. okay
a couple of other um super chats coming
in
do we have a name for the mumbling
female caller we
somebody called her um oh there was hold
on there was something related
whoops it was like hal doll holly or
something like that i don't remember
jay-z gamer says what are your thoughts
about texas democrats fled texas to
escape being arrested
and prevent the republican party from
passing voter suppression bills you know
honestly i've not i don't know the
details of the story
because i've been so tied up with other
stuff the last few days
um
pacman certainly isn't a true
progressive his anti-bernie comments in
16 still burn roughly
i suppose i voted for bernie in 16 what
an earth are you talking about
i was a bernie supporter that's a really
i i almost want a band for stupidity
i mean i'll leave it but it's a little
weird
all right other super chats i found the
rogan link for you pretending you didn't
know about crowder's comedy show but the
link won't send in a super chat email
info
davidpakman.com link in timecode and i
will get to it i still haven't seen that
in years
so i would love to check that out info
davidpakman.com
david what are your thoughts on the dnc
pushing for phone companies to police
private messages to combat coveted
misinformation
love your show yeah i would be against
that i haven't seen it but if that's
if that's what's being described i would
be against it
i asked in a live stream for a david
pakman hat two months later you started
to sell them i expect a free one just
kidding
all right yeah hats i think are
available
um all right very good
let's get oh i do have a few new
uh drops here i do have this
cefe cepha hyde that's a good one
i've got prompt then he went donald
trump yeah donald trump
we've got that and then we've got some
plasma material
oops that one's not valid
plasma plasma oh some of these are
invalid files that's weird
but i have the i guess i have just the
one plasma
um and i think that's basically it
i have it for new stuff
uh oh i do have this song that some
people
might like and then they did dumps they
call them
dumps big massive dumps uh in michigan
and pennsylvania
big massive dumpsters
[Music]
all right that's enough i think it might
be it's almost like too much
uh okay good so we're standing by for
joe beautiful song yeah i mean it's
right up there with vivaldi
um we're standing by for uh joe biden he
will very soon be addressing republican
voter suppression and we're very excited
to see that
we have volume here um ready to go so we
will know
when it uh when it gets started i see
someone saying david what are the valid
coupon codes right now
oh my goodness all right so here's the
membership website which now i can pull
up
instantly let's look at what coupon
codes we have that are working
so better 21 i know is a code
that gets you 211 a month all right
that's not bad
i know that sad trump is a code
that's a dollar eighty a month okay sad
trump's not bad
i know about indictment 21 that's also a
dollar 80 a month
what else did we have did we have felony
21
felony 21 is 210 a month
um you know for some reason
i remember a coupon code
cucked no more let's see if it works
huh it's a valid coupon code but it's
full price that's weird
i guess it's sort of like you're
self-cooking if you use a coupon code
and it doesn't even give you oh no no it
says invalid coupon oh no hold on okay
i guess that's not oh was it forever
cooked
now i don't remember no that's not valid
either
it seems the best code right now is sad
trump
a dollar eighty yeah the coup that guys
the coupon codes are all working as you
can obviously tell
okay so that is that
um oh okay let's look at yeah some of
these videos
so here's a woman who believes that
donald trump is going to be president
with jfk jr
as his vp uh oh wait hold on
well this is like too big all right here
we go
trump kennedy 2021 what what does that
shirt mean
i think that jfk jr is still alive the
guy who died in the plane crash in the
late 90s i think he's still alive i do
and he's he's going to come back and
be president with trump and this year i
hope so
but how would trump become president
this year there would be a new election
there's a lot of things i think have
happened and there's some things i think
i know and a lot of things i don't
okay and one thing you you do know is
jonathan she's aware there's a lot of
things she doesn't know that's good
kenny junior is still alive that's what
i believe okay
do you want to bet do you want to bet on
it i'll bet 100 that jfk jr doesn't come
back from the dead
well but she doesn't think he's dead but
i don't think he's dead
right she's not claiming resurrection oh
okay i'll i bet
[Laughter]
there's that um now let me mention one
thing about this you know there's people
who will say that is
merely mental illness but here's the
thing
the the subject matter of the fixations
and the delusions
is related to what's going on in the
news but it's not like that person would
be
mentally healthy were it not for that
particular belief she would just believe
some believe something else like
all the conspiracy stuff with vaccines
right now
it's not like if there was no covet and
no covet vaccine
all the people who are like oh you're
shedding virus and whatever
um it's not like they'd be totally
normal were it not
for the fact that they have these
vaccine beliefs they would just be on
something different
that's i think the important thing to
remember
here's some other stuff here's a woman
i think she pretends to faint
um i'm not even sure if this is
mask-related honestly let's see if we
can even figure this out
no it's cute it's you ah
do you see this oh my god
i never thought nothing like this would
happen to me she just tried to run and
hit me
and now she did you see how
you saw her right they all saw her
oh my god karen had a breakdown
she tried to hit me at your workers
she tried to hit me she tried to hit me
now i want security for you
oh my god okay so i think it was part
three
oh yeah here's the part where she gets
down on the ground and starts vibrating
you keep lying saying i'm threatening
you so i'm recording to protect myself
oh my god
[Music]
does anybody know what the conflict is
even about
yeah she's crazy lady
can she attack me and try to say i
attacked her you cut
look at this i've never been around an
adult who behave like this
i only see children behave like this
i've like in not once
and i've been at bars where people are
out of their mind drunk and stuff
like i've never seen anything like this
oh y'all better get this lady
i like birthdays
[Applause]
as she chases the woman with the camera
she says get her away from me all right
so that's one
i thought that in part three she oh oh
oh here's where she pretends to faint
now i've fainted for real many times
it's called vasovagal syncope um this is
not what fainting looks like this is
actually an interesting one let's see if
we can get a better angle from her why
don't you get away from me
go wherever you want to go
this is crazy
[Applause]
it's a very slow faint game
[Applause]
there you go
okay so that's not that's not what
fainting looks like um
all right so there's that and then this
is a different one that was sent to me
this is apparently so let's talk a
little bit about crew the cruise
industry okay as we wait for joe biden
here i have never been on a cruise
because
i i tend to get seasick and also
norovirus runs rampant on cruises
and i hate being a captive audience of
any kind
and anytime that they're you know
keeping you entertained because you
can't go anywhere else and you've got
one place that's providing the food
because you don't go
it's just it's not my idea of fun so i'm
not a cruise guy
especially after coronavirus after
during which is where we are right now
the last thing i'm doing is going on a
cruise but apparently even now at this
early stage of cruise
cruises resuming people are doing it and
here's a woman who tested positive for
the covid
and so she's being brought off the ship
like obviously
and um it just doesn't go well and it's
like here's another reason not to go on
a cruise
well i know i can't breed with this
huh ridiculous
yeah ridiculous i think she's saying she
can't breathe with the mask they're
forcing her to wear because she has
covered
they closed off the freaking floor in
our room
look at our luggage it's wrapped in
freaking plastic is that a staten island
accent i hear
well at least it won't get dirty at the
airport one good thing right
look they sanitize everything as if
we're really contagious
as if i really have covet well you
tested positive
i had coveted three months ago i have
high
positive antibodies
covet tests aren't antibody tests she
seems to be saying no i have antibodies
because i'm so strongly recovered
took the test at my doctor's office high
positive
look look look just just i like how
everyone around her is in a hazmat suit
there's an ambulance outside for us
oh wait you're not putting me in no
ambulance you're not putting me in a car
until keith comes down here
if he's if he's not down here i'm not
going in that i'm not going in unless he
comes down here
he's got to sign that paper and i want
to and and and i want a copy of it
no i said don't take me out now until
keith signs the paper
don't roll me [ __ ] back anymore
ah then don't take me down here i'll
jump right off this wheelchair if i get
hurt
you're gonna be doubly responsible put
the brakes on
right now i'm gonna be in charge of my
imagine testing positive for covid and
being like i just want to keep going
with the cruise
please take me away let's undock unmore
whatever it is uh starboard ahoy
no obviously you're getting off you have
coveted no [ __ ] life
i'm tired i'm royal caribbean telling me
what i gotta do when you're
[ __ ] lying to us
they're [ __ ] lying now what's funny
whoa
the message is don't cruise if you are
not vaccinated because you're a target
yeah that's how the virus works she's
like she's had an epiphany
you're way more likely to test positive
if you're not vaccinated that's actually
really good advice
anger they're gonna make me have a heart
attack
i'm gonna have a heart attack right now
i gotta stop get keith murphy down here
i feel dizzy well because you're
screaming and you have covered
this i feel very dizzy i have like i
have to
i'm getting i think i'm going to have a
heart attack
if i have a heart attack live on [ __ ]
instagram
won't this be a story for the freaking
press
i think the story is get yourself
vaccinated and don't go on cruises
[Applause]
all right things are starting uh joe
biden is here
all right so joe biden very strongly
coming in thanks to green man
c brown as well as uh i guess that's uh
all right uh
new twitch subscribers number 17 and 18.
also big thank you to quincy herman for
signing up with the code
sad trump deborah murphy is a new member
miles mckay is a new member
patricia mccarthy as well as patricia
mccarthy with two memberships very good
can we get them on mike please see an
awful lot of good friends out there
please have a seat if you have one i uh
let me begin by saying i used to be
important
i used to be the chairman of the board
of this place
and jeffrey rosen allowed me to do that
for a while
but thank you all for being here i truly
appreciate it governor
it's above and beyond the call mr mayor
i uh
i compliment i thought you're a great
mayor still think you are
but your judgment and fiance is even
stronger
and uh but but all of you and my good
friend bobby brady i see so many friends
out al sharpton al how are you pal
it's great to see you and uh
i'm i'm gonna get in trouble here
because i'm gonna
recognize my congresswoman from the
state of
lisa blunt rochester
and her sister who used to run my office
stand up
hey folks good afternoon
uh there's a serious subject i'd like to
talk about today i'm here in
philadelphia
the national constitution center the
city and the place where
the story of we the people we the people
began
it's a story that's neither simple nor
straightforward
that's because the story is the sum of
our parts
and all those parts are fundamentally
human
and being human is to be imperfect
driven by appetite and ambition
as much as by goodness and grace
but some things in america should be
simple and straightforward
like voting perhaps the most important
of those things the most
fundamental of those things is the right
to vote
the right to vote freely
the right to vote freely the right the
right to vote fairly
the right to have your vote counted
the democratic threshold is liberty
within anything's possible without it
nothing
nothing and for our democracy
and the work and to deliver our work and
our people it's up to all of us to
protect that right
this is a test of our time what i'm here
to talk about today
just think about the past election 102
year old woman
in arkansas who voted for the first time
on the very spot she once picked cotton
a 94 year old woman in michigan voted
early and in person
in her 72nd
consecutive election you know what she
said
said this election was quote the most
important vote
that we ever had the daughter who voted
in memory of her dad
who died of covet 19 so others wouldn't
have the experience of pain and darkness
and loss that she was going through
the patients out there and the po
and and the parents the parents who
voted for school
their children will learn it sons and
daughters voted
for the planet they're going to live on
young people
just turning 18 and everyone who for the
first time
in their lives thought they could truly
make a difference
america america and americans of every
background voted
they voted for good jobs and higher
wages
they voted for racial equity and justice
they voted to make health care right not
a privilege
and the reason that americans went to
vote and the lengths they went to vote
to be able to vote this past election
were absolutely extraordinary
right in fact the fact that so
many election officials across the
country made it easier and safer
for them to be able to vote in the
middle of a pandemic was remarkable
as a result in 2020
more people voted in america than ever
ever in the history of america in the
middle of a once-in-a-century
pandemic
all total more than 150 americans
of every age of every race every
background exercised their right to vote
they voted early they voted absentee
they voted in person
they voted by mail they voted by dropbox
and then
they got their families and friends to
go out and vote
election officials the entire electoral
system
withstood unrelenting political attacks
physical threats intimidation and
pressure
they did so with unyielding courage and
faith in our democracy
with recount after recount after recount
court case after court case the 2020
election was the most scrutinized
election ever
in american history challenge after
challenge
brought to local state and election
officials
state legislatures state and federal
courts
even to the united states supreme court
not once but
twice more than 80
judges including those appointed by my
predecessor
heard the arguments in every case
neither cause nor evidence was found to
undermine the national achievement of
administering the historic election
in the face of such extraordinary
challenges
audits recounts right were conducted
in arizona and wisconsin in georgia it
was recounted
three times it's clear
they found ballots with red miso paste
on it which was really suspicious
because they were supposedly from a a
particular region that's
more partial to the yellow miso scrutiny
and such high standards
the big lie is just that a big lie
the 2020 election it's not hyperbole
suggests the most examined
and the fullest expression of the will
of the people in the history of this
nation
this should be celebrated an example of
america at its best
but instead we continue to see an
example of human nature at its worst
something darker and more sinister
in america if you lose
you accept the results you follow the
constitution
you try again you don't call
facts fake and then try to bring down
the american experiment just because
you're unhappy
right no it's also because they're
idiots
he's right they're doing it because
they're unhappy bad people
and don't actually care about the
country selfishness that's not democracy
it's the denial
of the right to vote
it suppresses it subjugates
the denial of full and free and fair
election is the most un-american thing
than any of us can imagine the most
undemocratic
the most unpatriotic edge sadly
not unprecedented
from denying enslaved people full
citizenship
until the 13th 14th and 15th amendments
after the civil war
to nine women the right to vote until
the 19th amendment 100 years ago
to pull taxes and literacy tests and the
ku klux klan campaigns of violence and
terror
that lasted in the 50s and 60s to the
supreme court decision in 2013
and then again just two weeks ago a
decision that weakened
the landmark voting rights act to the
willful
attacks election attacks in 2020
and then to a whole other level of
threat
the violence and the deadly insurrection
on the capitol on january 6th
i just got back from europe speaking of
the g7
and the nato they wonder
not a joke they wonder gov they ask me
is it going to be okay the citadel
democracy in the world
is it all going to be okay time and
again we've weathered threats to the
right to vote in free and fair elections
in each time we found a way to overcome
and that's what we must do today
vice president harris and i have spent
our careers doing this work
and i've asked her to lead to bring
people together to protect the right to
vote in our democracy
and it starts with continuing the fight
to pass
h.r one the for the people act
can you imagine
that bill
that bill would help end voter
suppression in the states
get dark money out of politics give
voice to the people at the grassroots
level create
a fair district maps and end partisan
political gerrymandering
last month republicans
opposed even debating even considering
for the people's act senate democrats
stood united
to protect our democracy and the
sanctity of the vote
we must pass the for the people act
it's a national imperative we must also
fight
for the john lewis voting rights
advancement act to restore and expand
right
restore and expand voting protections
prevent voter suppression all the
congress women and men here there's a
bunch of you
you knew john many of you just weeks ago
supreme court yet again weaken the
voting rights act
and upheld what justice kagan called
quote a significant
race-based disparity in voting
opportunities
the court's decision as harmful as is
does not limit the congress's ability to
repair the damage done
that's the important point it puts the
burden back on congress to restore the
voting rights act
this is all great guys but it's like you
know when other countries look at us and
we're debating
voting as opposed to doing stuff you
know it's insane that this even is a
debate in this country
that will be an important moment
and the world is wondering
the world
and dwight knows what i'm talking about
for real
you know the world is wondering what is
america going to do
but we also have to be clear-eyed yeah
about the obstruction
we face here we go legislation is one
tool but not the only tool
and it's not the only measure of our
obligation to defend democracy today
for example attorney general merrick
garland announced that the united states
department of justice is going to be
using its authorities
to challenge the onslaught of state laws
undermining voting rights
in old and new ways focus
again it's like that's great you've got
to do it but imagine if instead they
could be doing other things that are
more productive because you didn't have
half the country fighting people's
ability to vote
george's vicious anti-voting law
the department of justice will do so
with a voting rights division
that my request is doubling its size
and enforcement staff civil rights
groups
civil rights groups and other
organizations have announced their plans
to stay
vigilant and challenge these odious laws
in the courts
in texas for example republican-led
state legislature wants to allow
partisan poll watchers to intimidate
voters
and imperil and impartial uh poll
workers
they want voters to dive further
and be able to be in a position where
they wonder who's watching them
and intimidating them to wait longer to
vote
to drive a hell of a lot long excuse me
a long way
to get to vote they want to make it so
hard and inconvenient
that they hope people don't vote at all
that's what this is about this year
alone
17 states have enacted not just proposed
but enacted
right 28 new laws to make it harder for
americans to vote
which we've covered not to mention and
catch this nearly
400 additional bills
republican members of the state
legislatures are trying to pass
the 21st century jim crow assault is
real
it's unrelenting and we're going to
challenge it vigorously
yes while
while this broad assault against voting
rights is not unprecedented
it's taking on a new and literally
pernicious forms
particularly gross just about who gets
to vote
that's a bunch of military for eligible
voters to vote
it's about who gets to count the vote
who gets to count whether or not your
vote counted at all
it's about moving from independent
election administrators
who work for the people to polarize
state legislatures
and partisan actors who work for
political parties
to me this is simple this is election
subversion
it's the most dangerous threat to voting
in the integrity of free and fair
elections in our history
never before they decided who gets to
count
count what votes count
right some some legislate legislators
want to make it harder for you to vote
and if you vote
they want to be able to tell your vote
doesn't count
for any reason they make up they want
the ability to reject the final count
and ignore the will of the people
if their preferred candidate loses
and they're trying not only targeting
people of color they're targeting voters
of all races and backgrounds
with a simple target who did not vote
for them
that's the target it's unconscionable
i mean really it's hard to
it's hard to declare just how critical
this is
it's simply unconscionable
we've got to shore up our election
system and address the threats to
elections aversion
not just from abroad which i spent time
with putin talking about
right but from home from home
we must ask those who represent us at
the federal state local levels
will you deny the will of the people
will you ignore their voices
we have to ask are you on the side of
truth or lies
fact or fiction justice or injustice
democracy or
autocracy that's what it's coming down
to
which brings me perhaps the most
important thing we have to do
we have to forge a coalition of
americans of every background a
political party
the advocates the students the faith
leaders the labor leaders the business
executives
and raise the urgency of this moment
because as much as people know they're
screwing around with the election
process i don't think
that most people think this is about who
gets to count what vote counts
literally not figuratively
you vote for certain electors to vote
for somebody for president
state legislator comes along under their
proposal
and they say no we don't like those
elections we're going to appoint other
electors we're going to vote for the
other guy or
other woman because here's the deal
in 2020 democracy was put to a test
first by the pandemic then by a
desperate attempt
to deny the reality and the results of
the election yeah we got a c on that
test we passed but barely
a violent and deadly insurrection on the
capitol
the citadel of our democracy i've been
around a long time in public life
i thought i've seen it all or most of it
all
but i never thought i'd see that for
real
and in spite of what you see on
television and you saw it
you have senators saying it was just a
day at the capitol
just people visiting the capitol
folks but we met the test
because of the extraordinary courage of
election officials
many of them republicans our court
system
those brave capital police officers
because of them
democracy held look how close it came i
mean for real how clearly
right we're going to face another test
in 2022 a new wave of unprecedented
voter suppression
and raw and sustained election
subversion
we have to prepare now as i said time
and again
no matter what you can never stop the
american people from voting
they will decide and the power must
always be with the people
that's why just like we did in 2020 we
have to prepare for 2022.
we'll engage in an all-out effort to
educate voters about the changing laws
it's going to be ugly register them to
vote and then get the vote out
come on man we encourage people to run
for office themselves
at every level we'll be asking my
republican friends in congress and
states and cities and counties
to stand up for god's sake and help
prevent
this concerted effort to undermine our
election
and the sacred right to vote please
give me up have you no shame
whether it's stopping foreign
interference in our elections with the
spread of disinformation
from within we have to work together
vice president harris and i will be
making it clear that there's
real peril in making raw power
rather than the idea of liberty the
centerpiece of the common life
founders understood this the women of
seneca falls understood this
the brave heroic foot soldier of the
civil rights movement understood this
so must we this isn't about democrats or
republicans
it's literally about who we are as
americans it's that basic
it's about the kind of country we want
today
the kind of country we want for our
children and grandchildren tomorrow
and quite frankly the whole world is
watching
folks
that's a bunch of milwaukee i'm not
being
sentimental i'm not preaching to you
i'm just giving it to you straight as i
promised i would always do
lay things out on the line honor your
trust with
trust so hear me clearly
there's an unfolding assault
taking place in america today an attempt
to suppress and subvert
the right to vote and fair and free
elections
an assault on democracy an assault on
liberty
an assault on who we are
who we are as americans for make no
mistake
bullies and merchants of fear peddlers
of lies
are threatening the very foundation of
our country
it gives me no pleasure to say this i
never thought my entire career i'd ever
have to say it
but i swore a note to you to god
to preserve protect and defend the
constitution whoa
that's an oath that forms a sacred trust
to defend america against all threats
both foreign
and domestic
the assault on free and fair elections
is just such a threat
literally i've said it before
we're facing the most significant test
of our democracy
since the civil war that's not hyperbole
since the civil war
the confederates back then never
breached the capitol
as insurrectionists did on january the
6th
not saying this alarm you i'm saying
this because you
should be alarmed yes i'm also saying
this
there's good news it doesn't have to be
this way
it doesn't have to be for real we have
the means
we just need the will
the will to save and strengthen our
democracy
we didn't we did in the 2020. the battle
for the soul of america
in that battle the people voted
democracy prevailed
our constitution held we have to do it
again
my fellow americans requires
fair-mindedness
devotion to justice corny as it sounds
love a country requires us to unite in
common purposes declares
here and now we the people will never
give up we will not give in
we will overcome we will do it together
from guaranteeing the right to vote
ensuring every vote is counted
has always been the most patriotic thing
we can do
just remember our late friend john lewis
said
freedom is not a state it's an act
freedom is not a state it's an act
and we must act and we will act for our
cause is just
our vision is clear and our hearts are
full
for we the people for our democracy for
america itself
we must act god bless you all and may
god protect our troops
and all those who stand to watch over
our democracy
[Applause]
so uh joe biden with a uh
powerful end to his speech
going directly at really everyone on the
right who has been making a mockery of
the election system
uh and now the question is will anything
be done
this is all crazy what's happening uh
various dignitaries and guests in
philadelphia pennsylvania
joe biden seemingly completely swallowed
up by the crowd
this guy looks like matt whitaker right
here
kind of interesting hopefully it's not
matt whitaker because it looks like that
guy may be part of secret service
and i would not want matt whitaker
anywhere near joe biden
a mask-less vaccinated crowd presumably
[Music]
okay right so some questions came in
via super chat during this what's more
important joe the right to vote or
upholding the filibuster yeah that's a
fair question
it's a fair question biden to
republicans have you no
shame no no they don't that's the
problem
david the sound bites make me literally
cackle out loud in the middle of what
would otherwise be a serious speech
i absolutely love them dumps
david what do you think of the pbs
newshour being a reliable source i never
watch it
do you watch it yourself i never watch
it why do you suppose right-wing media
don't go after pbs newshour i don't know
i'm not saying it's unreliable i just
don't really watch news shows at all
i just have so much to kind of stay up
on that
consuming news via audio visual means
is just too slow i prefer to read
will you be covering how texas
republican congressmen are
attempting to arrest democratic
lawmakers protesting
the voter suppression bill yes
yes i absolutely will tomorrow
david did you hear jenna ellis is
leaving the republican party
i did and i am i that's on today's show
actually that's on today's show
and in fact we've got to go finish
getting today's show out all right so
thank you to everybody for joining me
it's been truly an incredible and an
historic day and we will all be back
with everything really really soon
[Music]
if you're thinking about joining the
david
backman show he's got a lot of
content don't you know
search a subject but don't forget to
add his name at the end of the subject
he'll hit you with some facts
empirical at that
and once or twice a week he'll mention
about
his
you gardening also know
that there is